Jim Rohn is one of the fathers of
personal development he was Tony
robbins's personal mentor and influenced
other greats like Jack Canfield Mark
Victor Hansen and Brian Tracy what
you're about to watch is the last video
interview that Jim Rohn ever did he sits
down with Chris Weidner to talk about
how to get the right mentors set
meaningful goals and stop being broke
and we got Chris's permission to put it
up on our YouTube channel enjoy my guest
today is Jim Rohn Jim has been hailed
over the years as one of the most
influential thinkers of our time and
considered to be America's foremost
business philosopher he has been sharing
his success philosophies for over 40
years to over 4 million people worldwide
Jim Rohn has helped motivate and train
an entire generation of personal
development trainers as well as hundreds
of Executives from America's Top
corporations he is a master motivator
author and a living legend welcome Jim
wow Chris thank you very much good to
have you here I'll take you with me
around the world just enter yeah so I
want to ask you you know we we were
talking as we did the run through for
the promo there about being a living
legend and you really are I mean you
have had an incredible life an
exceptional life where you've been able
to influence so many people
how do you go from the kid that you
started out to you know where you're at
now speaking all over the world how do
you get started in that well
part of it is living long enough to have
a chance to be a legend right there you
go and I just celebrated birthday number
75. but uh 25 years old I'm living in uh
Idaho where I was born and raised and
um
you know I'm married I've got a little
family
started and struggling to pay my bills
but you know working hard doing the best
I can
and uh then you've heard the story this
I get this knock on the door
and um there's a little girl scout
selling Girl Scout cookies
and she gives me this incredible
presentation Girl Scouts best
organization in the world
everybody wants to support the Girl
Scouts we've got these cookies only two
dollars and she very politely asked me
to buy
no problem I wanted to buy big problem I
didn't have two dollars in my pocket
you know and I'm not destitute but my
pockets are empty
I'm a grown man I'm 25 years old I've
been to one year of college I got a
little family going I live in America
and I don't have the two dollars in my
pocket and I didn't want to tell her
that
so I did what I thought was next best I
lied to her
and I said hey look I've already bought
lots of Girl Scout cookies we've still
got plenty in the house we haven't eaten
yet she said oh that's wonderful thank
you very much and she leaves when she
leaves
I say to myself I don't want to live
like this anymore
I mean how low can you get lying to a
Girl Scout right exactly so that was one
of those days I call the day that turns
your life around when I really made the
commitment I must start a search
for finding ways to to do better I
always wanted to but I just hadn't found
the person or the ways shortly after
that I found someone who became my
mentor over a five-year period after
that between ages 25 and uh and 30 31.
um what he taught me made me a
millionaire
um entrepreneur
changed my life
refine My Philosophy
help me develop skills and disciplines
that I didn't have before
totally revolutionized my life over that
five-year period
and that was the beginning of
my change of uh mind and and
circumstances and then that led to where
I am today I wonder how many people have
that dramatic moment like you did you
shut that door and you went I just lied
to a Girl Scout person some people could
have just said well yeah I had to do
what I had to do other people like
yourself Say Never Again yeah you don't
know I call it the mystery and the magic
why one experience affects a person one
way and another person passes it off and
doesn't let out doesn't let it change
their life for the better
or they might not do it now and maybe
later something else will happen and
that that'll be the moment you just
don't know
as you know lecturing giving seminars
teaching training
you know why some people pick it up do
something with it change their lives and
others don't
I remember at the 2004 weekend
leadership event we had someone come
back who had been to the 2001 and they
were in real estate and they had bought
some outrageous amount of real estate
you know 50 million dollars in the lab
because they walked out of the last one
so and then another guy was there and he
said I was at the same one but he went
out and did it and I didn't well he was
back for 2004 he said in 2007. he said
I'm coming back and I will have built my
fortune yeah that's that's part of the
mystery you know I've written how many
books now five or six and uh
um I should have written 26.
so what happened to those other 20 books
that's the mystery you know the magic is
the six and the Mystery is the 20 that
are missing so we're a bit of a mystery
to ourselves right yeah sure I should
have but I didn't you know I had the
skills but I didn't put them to work
uh so we all have a bit of that but then
the things we do that sort of
dramatically change our life that's the
magic that's the that's the power yeah
part of it is the law of averages
you know I tell this little Bible story
about the sore went out to sow the seed
and he was highly ambitious and he had
good seed but the first
part of the seed that he sowed the birds
got
and the next he keeps going and the next
seed falls on uh Thorn uh Stony ground
where the soil is shallow and the little
plant starts to grow in the first hot
day it Withers and dies so he keeps on
going the next seed that he sowed
fell on thorny ground yeah a little
plant starts to grow and then the Thorns
choke it to death and it called the
Thorns little cares little things that
keep people from doing the bigger things
and then finally
he keeps on sowing and the seed Falls
finally on good ground
but then the good ground was a bit of a
an interesting
idea that some of it produced 30 percent
some of it produced 60 and some of it
produced a hundred
so it's the full range from the birds
getting some and the hot weather and the
Thorns to the good ground even though
good ground has a variety of 30 60 100.
so when I started out lecturing I
wondered why I couldn't get everybody to
do the 100 then I found out you know
this this is not to be right you know so
that when I say to John you should have
been at the meeting last night and he
said well hey the screen screen door
came off the hinges I had to fix and do
some repairs
and so I say now I understand yeah that
some people are going to let little
things cheat them out of doing better
things
but maybe that'll change yeah yeah you
know a week from now somebody wakes up
and has an experience like I did with
the with the Girl Scout and uh and
everything changes so the doer usually
is always open
unless somebody totally resists the idea
of
self-improvement I think there's enough
experiences along the way to protest and
push us a little bit or we hear a
testimonial or read a book right or
somebody buys us a ticket and we go to a
seminar and we're never the same again
you share an idea with someone two
people one of them says I see it and the
other one says it isn't clear to me
why not and it's perfectly clear when
you shared it yeah why can't you see
what I see yeah true we all how come you
don't feel like I feel so you have to
allow for that and then we have to allow
for it happening Even in our own
experience like me with the missing
books
I should have and I didn't I let it go
and I should have picked it up
um so I guess the key is to do the best
we can
and the key is to keep learning from
every experience possible
our own personal experiences or from
someone else's experiences by sermon the
lyrics of a song a personal testimonial
someone gives you sitting at Denny's for
a Tuesday morning breakfast and
something clicks and something happens
you never know yeah those moments are a
kind of a mixture of everything coming
together right timing and your own
personal circumstances so you end up
going to work for Earl shelf and you had
lots of lessons to learn what was that
secure seven year period I was he was
with me about five years then he died
but at the early age of 49. but uh those
were such dramatic days of incredible
change
and the stuff he taught he only went to
the ninth grade in school so he puts
things very simply for the excuses I
gave he said no those are not the
reasons I said things cost too much he
said no you can't afford him you know
little philosophies like that that
opened my eyes to see what was the story
where you brought him a paycheck he said
this is all they pay yeah this is all
the page no this is all they pay you
right I guess so don't Summit the
company make three four five times as
much and I said well yes and he says
well this is not all they pay this is
all they pay you yeah if you qualified
for the 10 times this wouldn't they pay
you that amount and I said I guess they
would of course he said well let's go to
work on that yeah we don't have to go to
work on the company for more pay we got
to go to work on you to become more
qualified yeah they have pay structure
already set up for somebody you got to
fit into that then when I in my lectures
I show the this little economic
staircase you know ladder to climb it
starts at five dollars an hour and goes
all the way up to 32 million for one
year right one year's annual income and
uh somewhere along the way
by what we hear and what we experience
we try to make ourselves better
qualified for the next to move up yeah
and that's the key is to keep moving up
keep growing keep developing see what
all you can do with your life
what uh he was really the first person
to give you the idea of personal
development right what
kinds of things was he telling you about
the importance of developing yourself
what were some of those lessons that he
does want to use which got really got my
attention he said why don't you set a
goal to become a millionaire I'm 25
years old he said this is America land
of opportunity why don't you set a goal
to become a millionaire
and then he said for what it will make
of you to achieve it
and I thought wow that's a whole
different philosophy
set a goal to become a millionaire for
what for the person you have to become
in order to be worth a million dollars
then he said once you've become a
millionaire you give the money away
because what's important is not what you
got but the person you became and I got
the message
and that's where I started hearing those
phrases from him work harder on yourself
than you do on your job
um
bringing value to the marketplace is how
you get paid the more value you bring to
the marketplace the better your pay and
also you get paid for what you become a
leader an entrepreneur
a manager somebody who has the ability
to inspire other people so somebody's
watching and they're saying okay work
harder on yourself than you do on your
job
and they they're they're they agree with
it in principle they say yeah that
sounds right I know I need to work on
myself what is what would you recommend
people do I started out with developing
a list of skills I didn't have
you know I'm raised in farm country
Southwest Idaho right I know how to milk
cows but the pay is not good
that's right so the first thing and I
started part-time
um a little uh sales Adventure on how to
get customers
it was in health and nutrition
and I believed in the product and I was
taught here's how you get a customer and
then here's how you ask them who do they
know that wants to be healthier
um then
um
expand your business from there so that
was the first extra skill I learned
from just the regular Farm skills that
started to change my life so this is
part of the personal development
learning that extra skill in my seminars
I now teach in the 21st century you need
more than one skill
one is for economic safety right here's
the guys that's worked for General
Motors they just what closed a couple of
plants and laid off what I don't know 25
000 people this guy has been there let's
say for 15 years now he's laid off and
he tells us he's already having economic
difficulty and the reason is Chris he
only had one skill
you know over the last three or four
years if he would have taken accounting
two nights a week
or something yeah so that when this
crisis occurred he would have something
to fall back on
so in my seminars I teach a whole list
of skills I learned uh but the time I
was uh 30 31 that not only made me Rich
but uh really broadened the whole scope
of my ability to be an entrepreneur
affect other people's lives and then I
got into of course teaching and training
but that's part of it I learned sales I
learned to find good people
I learned to get people to work together
interesting phrase in the Bible says if
two or three agree on a common purpose
nothing's impossible I thought wow two
or three not all alone but two or three
so if you can
get inspired and inspire a couple of
people to go with you you could do some
pretty extraordinary things I learned
how to do that then I learned uh
recognition
and reward rewarding people for steps of
progress
you may work for a company and they
reward people for the big steps I've
learned to reward people for little
small steps of progress anything you can
think of to give them a reward for
making uh some progress it doesn't have
to be a big reward it doesn't have to be
something small kind word then it comes
to a philosophy that says
be so busy giving other people
recognition you really don't need it for
yourself
now you've arrived at a very good place
your greatest happiness is
other people getting rewards not
necessarily yourself
but then Zig comes back with the old
philosophy that's so true if you help
enough people
get what they want from either money to
recognition or success
you can have everything you want yeah I
heard ziggs say that I think almost 50
years ago 45 Plus
and uh
when he said you can have everything you
want
I underlined the word everything
I think Zig is a right if you help
enough people get what they want yeah
but that's another skill
then I think the ultimate skill is the
skill of communication
and I divided that one into three parts
one is training right showing somebody
how to do the job next is teaching
and I simply use the two words for a
purpose
teaching life skills
because one of the things that helped me
really revolutionize my life age 25 was
learning how to set goals decide what
you want write it down start checking
them off where do you want to go make
that list what do you want for your
family make that list I started doing
all that that's called teaching teaching
life skills
so if you combine job skills with life
skills your chances now really start to
multiply
then the ultimate in communication is
learning to inspire
helping somebody to see themselves
better than they are
transporting them into the future say
Mary here's who you could become with
just a few changes I promise you you'll
never be the same again here's the kind
of person you could become confident
strong
able to cope with circumstances and
changes you could be that person
I think that that is something that
anybody can do I mean when typically
when people think of leaders they think
of the heads of you know captains of
industry and presidents and you know
leaders of social movements is that
something somebody do middle management
in their own sure career parents parents
should even learn to do it at home
here's the person you could become
um
we try every means possible right
especially for our children yeah to
expose them ideas that we know we
translate best we can or from church or
hopefully from school
um from the neighborhood from the
business Community where they might get
a job and go to work we just hope and
pray
that they will be constantly exposed to
things that will cause them to think
change refine habits develop skills
have personal satisfaction of the
success they want we hope that happens
but it's going to come from a variety of
sources not just one
it's like mentoring I happen to find
somebody who you know was the business
employer uh business partner that I
worked with as well as being a mentor
sometimes you know somebody mentors you
in good health somebody else mentors you
in spiritual matters someone else
mentors you in family relations and
someone else mentors you in business and
developing skills did you go looking
actively looking for mentors throughout
your life uh no after that girl scout
experience
um
I said to myself I must find something
and sure enough a friend of mine said
I've gone to work with this man you've
got a meeting that was shortly after
that I met Mr Show
and who knows the mystery of that right
yeah
um when a student is ready the teacher
appears yeah when you have that
determination
like things start you know happening and
coming your way yeah at least the odds
are better yeah everything's a matter of
odds but if you do certain things I
think you can increase your odds the
better things will happen for you
so after you became successful in your
business then uh there was a phone call
you got a phone call right and somebody
said hey come and talk it to us yeah I
moved to Beverly Hills because that's
what you should do when you become
successful yeah a kid from the farm
country of Idaho moved to if you got
rich Beverly Hills
so when I get there a friend of mine
said you've got to come and tell your
story to my service Club you belong to
the Rotary
and he said if I arrange this uh
breakfast meeting I think our luncheon
meeting he said would you come you know
just do a little 30 minute talk and tell
your story
and he said we'll call it Idaho Farm Boy
makes it to Beverly Hills I said okay
suits me
so I did this little talk
and uh evidently they enjoyed it before
the day was over I got a couple more
invitations you got to come talk to our
service Club tell that same story share
those same ideas that started me
thinking about
um you know
really becoming involved in teaching and
training I've done a lot of training
yeah and inspiring in my own
entrepreneurial organizations but uh not
not for the public so I started doing
these little talks for service clubs and
once in a while a high school class
college class enjoying it very much then
one day a man
said to me uh I've heard your talk now
two or three times and I've got this
little company going
and he said if you would come make a
presentation I'd be happy to pay you and
I thought incredible there's a job yeah
could I really share my story and get
paid he said I'll be happy to do it wow
so I did that then that led to another
one and another one then later on the
idea occurred why not have uh some
Representatives out
selling tickets
to come and hear a public seminar yeah
and we finally put that together and
that was you know all those many many
years ago tell us a little bit about
that this is a kind of a peek behind the
scenes of because you're really one of
the Pioneers you and Zig and some of the
other folks cavitt Roberts and some of
those what was the what was the culture
like back then when when you guys were
out barnstorming America and really
developing the whole personal
development culture that now is so
prominent in America what was that like
it was exciting of course mine I gave it
all away in all the speeches I did and
colleges the high schools and first
service clubs and so on that was all
free then when somebody offered to pay
me that put a whole new look on it and
then I began this process of creating
something valuable enough to where
someone would buy a ticket and go and
listen
and those were exciting days
the first one I did for pay I think I
had about 45 or 50
participants that bought tickets
a lot of them were friends of mine that
I'm sure bought because they were
friends of mine but there were some
others that you know legitimately bought
at the Beverly Hilton Hotel in Beverly
Hills
and that first public seminar for people
buying tickets I think was
1961 or 62 1962. wow
and then that started it started growing
from there yeah and uh developed to
where I am now traveling the world and
telling my story and still sharing ideas
yeah but uh it was it was a fantastic
time Earl Nightingale right yeah it was
way back in the beginning
Napoleon Hill with his lecture series
way back before was probably one of the
first
they started calling it self-help
movement yeah
and uh then came along the phrase
personal development shof talked about
personal development
work harder on yourself than you do on
your job he said yeah if you work hard
on your job you can make a living which
is fine if you work hard on yourself you
can make a fortune which is super fine I
thought this is good philosophy yeah so
did you guys ever get together and do
big events with you know you and Zig and
Norman Vincent Peale yeah finally over
the years American Sales Masters all of
that way back that goes way back huh
yeah
I remember the first time I did a
multi-speaker and I think was in St
Louis it was about uh I don't know
nine ten thousand people there in one of
the big auditoriums Zeke was there and I
was there Norman Vincent Pio was there a
couple of others
and uh this is the time when sieg said
to me said Jim Rohn said you got to pay
attention and you got to really be good
today in your presentation because he
said if ten thousand people turn on you
it is going to be a difficult day
foreign
I gotta do my best Zig may be right if I
don't do well you know I will incur the
wrath of these 10 000 people but that
was uh that was good advice
I learned along the way to pay more
attention to the audience
way back in the early days I was more
absorbed in my lecture and what I was
having to say you know people could have
left and I probably wouldn't have really
known it but then I got to where I could
look up and you know find out what's
going on out in the audience are they
getting it and is it coming across and I
teach that now in some of my seminars
yeah when you think back to those
speakers who really stands out in your
mind as as being somebody that you
really admired and respected yeah Zig
Ziglar was you know we've traveled gone
to other countries to lecture uh on the
same venue
um Earl Nightingale was a was unique you
know a unique person in his own
his own right the stuff that he wrote as
well as his uh speeches and lectures uh
or captivating uh interesting made you
listen
thought-provoking and that's all we're
really trying to do right yeah the
minister on Sunday morning right just
wants to share ideas get people thinking
pondering about their life
how do we find things spiritually as
well as how to refine things
economically and personally yeah
and we can all use a little coaching
whether it's one-on-one person or
whether it's in a seminar setting or
whether it's church or Sunday school
class or wherever it is
or ideas are being shared there's always
a chance to pick up something that you
hadn't quite thought about before
there's Chris Weidner and I hope that
you're really enjoying this interview
that I did with Jim uh you can tell that
it was a little while ago you can see
how young I looked in that video it was
such an amazing opportunity uh to be
able to work with Jim Rohn but then to
be able to interview him which we didn't
know at the time this would become the
last video interview that Jim ever did
so I hope that you're enjoying it uh
some uh some wisdom from one of the
great Legends and I've got some amazing
resources for entrepreneurs uh that are
available to you all you have to do is
just go down and check in the uh in the
comments in the links below and you'll
be able to see some other great
resources so let's get back to uh
listening to the great wisdom of the
legendary Jim Rohn
in 2004 summer 2004
um you got the masters of influence
award at the National Speakers
Association and I was there to be able
to to be there and see that and one of
the things that really amazed me was
they asked the crowd and there was maybe
2 000 people there two three thousand
people there
um how many of you would say that Jim
Rohn has significantly influenced your
life or your speaking career and nearly
two-thirds of the hands went up how do
you feel about that it's you know it's
it's so extraordinary from where I came
from yeah Southwest Idaho Farm country
I still have the old Family Farm
overlooking the Snake River
where I make a little wine and you know
grow a few crops and live The Good Life
there
but it is extraordinary
um
one of the greatest experiences and
you've heard me say before is when
someone
puts your name in in their testimonial
oh here's the person that found me
here's the person that got me started
here's the person that wouldn't let me
quit
gave me more reasons for staying than
for leaving
here's the person who believed in me
until I could believe in myself and then
they mentioned your name yeah yeah
that's Big Time stuff yeah you can't buy
it with money yeah you have to earn it
what's extraordinary for me now is to go
to Russia and lecture
uh I started lecturing in Russia 12
years ago to go back now again and have
someone say 12 years ago here's what's
happened to me my family I want to
introduce you to some people I've helped
change their lives since you changed my
life that's so extraordinary I guess
that's why at age 75 I am still off to
uh Chile in Santiago in a few days after
that Australia then uh three cities I
think in India and South Korea
one little trip yeah I want to talk to
you about your travels and it's one of
the fun things about having speakers
like yourself who come in who do World
Travel and to really just ask them what
what's the world like you know there's a
lot of people who are watching the show
who they don't get a chance to travel
that much you know and we hear things in
the American Media or whatever but what
are some of the countries that you've
loved to spend time in and what do you
think the average person should know
about some of these countries and
cultures
uh speaking of the travel you know I
used to travel to Concord oh before they
shut it all down three hours from London
to New York
so extraordinary now Singapore's got
this new flight Los Angeles to Singapore
Direct
uh uh 17 and a half hours
so that's quite an experience yeah you
know it's like nine meals and four
movies and uh finally you get there yeah
but uh first class is you know exciting
and caviar and champagne and you know
all the
amenities
but um
traveling to other countries it you know
people are basically the same
you know they've got families and they
want to do well and
they want the Next Generation to be
better off than than they are
um people have hopes and dreams
want to know how they can achieve
success what could I do seems like I've
been stuck for four or five years what
could I do to make a difference
everybody wants to know
and then they want to be fulfilled
people want to you know have
satisfaction whether it's a spiritually
socially personally
satisfaction of personal development
I'm better than I used to be and I think
if I keep working hard I stand an
excellent chance of being better in the
future than I've been in the past
uh those kind of aspirations no matter
where I go
from South Africa to Scandinavia
from Korea to India to
uh
Vladivostok Russia
doesn't matter people are basically
the same have the same desires
some of the forms of government are a
bit different yeah but not the
aspirations of the people do you take
particular Joy going to countries where
there's burgeoning capitalistic
societies yeah yeah what is fun for me
is uh is uh the opportunity to teach
capitalism in Russia over the last 12
years I've been there like five times in
all the major cities
because they didn't have any concept of
capitalism all those years under
communism because communism taught
Capital belongs to the state not the
people
and of course we believe Capital belongs
to the people not the state a total
different economic philosophy but now
since the walls came tumbling down in
Germany what 14 15 years ago now they
have the opportunity
to become entrepreneurs and capitalism
personal responsibility instead of uh
they're always relying on the state so
it's all changing and they're hungry
aren't they just you know they're ready
for it
and uh of course the same mystery and
Magic occurs in Russia like it does
everywhere else yeah you tell you here's
how you can dramatically change your
life from pennies to Fortune and uh some
say yes that's great I will and some say
I'm not sure that's for me and I have to
learn to accept that right
I want to talk a little bit about kids
because you have a lot of a lot of
thoughts and theories about things that
kids should learn lessons they should
learn uh tell us about something one of
the easiest is capitalism because I use
it even in Russia teaching capitalism
that even kids can you know
become capitalists yeah because all it
involves is um
here's a 12 year old couldn't he search
the neighborhood
doesn't have to be twelve seven or eight
eight years old let's say this little
kid and he searches the neighborhood
finds a little broken wagon
and pays a dollar for it
and brings it home
fixes it up
paints it until it shines straighten out
the wheels until they're true takes it
back to the neighborhood and sells it
for five dollars
makes a four dollar profit
could that be possible and everybody
says well yes it could be possible and
all he would do have to have is the idea
so I'm teaching kids how to have two
bicycles one to ride and one to rent
right you don't have to be General
Motors to make a profit yeah so just a
bit of Ingenuity you know from the
lemonade stand or whatever those are
just all examples of of capitalism at
work where you make something and sell
it or you buy something and sell it
um
then teaching kids a little bit about
money management yeah I think is
important what are the things that they
ought to learn don't spend more than 70
cents out of every dollar
and then 10 cents
for charity or church
another 10 cents for active capital
like find a broken wagon pay a dollar
for it fix it sell it for five
that's active capital
and then last 10 percent is a passive
capital
let someone else use your money
invest it and let them pay you interest
or whatever
so a good good program for kids to learn
70 10 and 10. yeah
and if you do that over a reasonable
period of time you'll become financially
independent isn't it funny how human
nature even at that little kid level is
to spend it all yeah and then some more
yeah and borrow and spend some more so
the way you teach it is
could a child buy a bottle of soap for
two dollars and sell it for three
the answer is yes he goes Johnny goes
next door and says Mrs Brown Mama uses
this soap it's really good it's only
three dollars
and Mrs Brown says Johnny
I've really got plenty of soap and he
says you better let me come in and check
kids don't have to go to class that's
right they don't take no for an answer
so they don't need sales training
so she says well okay probably I do
here's three dollars and so she buys
this bottle of soap that Johnny bought
for two dollars she pays him three
dollars
now we say to John here's what you must
learn to do with the three dollars
and we just ask obvious questions what
if you took this three dollars now that
you just collected from Mrs Brown and
went and spent it all
he says well no you can't do that
because then you'd be out of business
that's right I mean some adults don't
know that
I think the money they got in their hand
you know if someone comes up you know
why not spend it say no you'd be out of
business yeah you got to save at least
two dollars back so you can go and buy
another bottle so yeah and uh sell it
for three and make another dollar then
kids learning to employ other kids yeah
Johnny Moes Mrs Brown's lawn she pays
five dollars
the idea occurs to him why couldn't I
get Pete to mow Mrs Brown's lawn collect
the five dollars
and uh give him a dollar
or two
for mowing the lawn and I keep the three
for getting the business
he says good idea
Mrs Brown gets her lawn mower
Pete gets a couple of dollars johnny
makes three for getting the job
and he said if you do a good job Pete
I'll have another person I'll have
another place to mow a lawn and first
thing you know it doesn't have to be
huge amounts just so you understand what
capital is all about
capital is any value you set aside to be
invested in an Enterprise
that brings value to the marketplace
hoping to make a profit that's
capitalism in one sentence
and it can be uh Capital money or
Capital time
you set aside to be invested
then I teach in Russia that the time and
the money you set aside to be invested
is like Seed corn
if a farmer has Seed corn that he's
going to plant hoping for a harvest come
Harvest Time would he eat it
the seed corn the answer is no would he
feed it to his family
and the answer is no of course not right
would he give it away and be generous
and say well no you can't be generous
with your seed corn
he would protect it by all means
because it's the only way it can
multiply and grow into more than what it
is
and that's what capitalism is all about
a chance for something to grow and
multiply into more than what it is but
you've got to protect it
the same is true with your time
let's say you set aside a certain amount
of time every week to invest in this
Enterprise that's going to bring value
to the marketplace hoping to make a
profit you can't let anybody have that
time you know
why is it that we what if you asked a
farmer what if you asked a farmer to go
bowling in the spring
he would say that's insane he can't do
it you can't go probably him that's free
call me the winner it's just like a
little short Seasons free we got the
lights on the tractors now where we go
you know around the clock yeah
Springtime short season got to get the
crops in so that that's capital time and
you have to learn the value of capital
time it's so easy to let somebody steal
your time that should be invested why do
we let people steal our time because it
seems to be Universal I don't know we
just don't set it up and you know stick
to it yeah it's just like wasting time
on a lot of things years and years ago I
asked a young man one time because I
knew we watched television a lot I said
how much did your television cost and he
said uh four hundred dollars
and I said well you really miscalculated
he said no it costs 400 I said that's to
buy it
do you think it costs to watch it wow
because I knew he had some skills that
he really wasn't employing and was
letting it all slide I said in my
personal opinion because the average
American now watches television six
seven hours a day I said in my personal
opinion this television is costing you
about forty thousand dollars a year not
to own it
but to watch it huh
and I said that's too much to pay right
I'll pick maybe 4 000 but not right come
on pay the four thousand and throw it
away and don't use it you'll still be
ahead of the game so
it sometimes all it takes is a
revolutionary idea like that someone
says I think Jim rohn's right this
television is costing me too much money
to watch it
because if I would use that same time
employing myself finding ways to make a
profit whatever
no telling what would happen yeah what
about but unless somebody comes along
and sort of you know shakes up the
basket and talks about things like that
uh on our own we could think about it
eventually but uh sometimes it's you
know it's a bit late yeah because that's
why when shof I said things cost too
much and he said no you can't afford him
I hadn't thought about that before
you know and I said this is all the
company pays he says no that's all they
pay you
and without that kind of sort of counsel
or guidance or reminder
it's easy to drift along a few more
years without making the necessary
changes to make your life better and he
was pointing the responsibility back to
you always always about you yeah
he said you've been working now six
years I quit school when I was 19 I'm
now I'm now 25 that's six years he said
you've been working now six years how
are you doing and I said not very well
he said I suggest you not do that
anymore
he said would you like to repeat the
next six years like the last six and I
says not really he said would you like
to revolutionize the next six years
versus the last six
and I said yes
and over the next six year period
I became a millionaire
you say isn't that amazing it is I mean
from the first six to the second sixth
same period of Time same period of time
with a whole totally different
philosophy yeah multiple skills learning
to be an entrepreneur uh you know
zigzole philosophy if you help enough
people get what they want you have
everything you want understanding all of
that
John Kennedy said don't ask what the
country can do for you that's not how
you get rich
ask what could I do for my country
starting with my neighbors starting with
my family is there some service I could
render some product I could represent
what could I do for the people of the
country and if you start thinking about
that entrepreneurially
now you can have some extraordinary life
change and it happened to me over that
next six years versus the last six what
a difference and the difference was not
the country you don't have to leave the
country
and the difference was not the economy
the economy that second six years of my
working life was about the same as it
was the first six years so the
difference was not and the difference
was not circumstances
you know some Winters are long and some
are short you know that's going to
happen in any six year period but uh the
difference now is your own refined
philosophy
and how you think about things that's
why you've got to welcome every chance
to listen to the lyrics of a song
um or uh the sermon on Sunday morning
the teacher
the professor
someone who like you
recommends good ideas to someone
who will take the time to listen that is
all so valuable
and collected over a period of time
compounded into activity and disciplines
fortunes can come your way yeah you and
your friend Charlie Jones talk an awful
lot about books that we become the
product of the books we read and the
people we meet audio programs we listen
to what books have shaped your life the
most you know it started with the Bible
my parents made sure I was a pretty good
scholar by the time I was 19.
that's 66 books now that's not very
politically correct to say that the
Bible right so but that's but it's a
collection of 66 books you know whatever
you might think about it yeah uh it's
had such excellent recommendation over
such a long period of time that it's not
a bad idea to at least have a look yeah
yeah you don't have to agree but it
would be I think not wise not it would
be unwise not to look at least check it
out what are your what are your favorite
thoughts from the Bible
one I'm using currently which I think is
so valid
is the
paraphrasing it the Storyteller says
there were two nice people
the story of two nice people not an evil
person and a good person but two nice
people
and the Storyteller goes on to say
however
and this is where the drama of Life
Begins however
one built his house on the rock and the
other built his house on the sand and in
just one sentence
we we understand we comprehend
well yes
no matter how nice you are if you build
your house on the sand come on
then it says the storms came as they
always do and everybody says well yes
we've got to recognize that and the one
that built his house on the rock was
saved and the one that built his house
on the sand was lost both nice
people
which means nice people can make errors
in judgment nice people can make
careless decisions
nice people can make foolish decisions
sometimes even fatal
here's a nice guy he's married got a
wonderful family
he lives in Los Angeles
he's a good citizen of the community
this is a nice guy
he's ambitious he does well
he's in Los Angeles driving his car and
he's late for an appointment and he's
pushing it pushing it pushing it and he
comes to the intersection
and the light turns red and a little
voice in his head says go ahead you're
late you can make it and now he's dead
nice guy
but he's dead when in a split second of
time he made a foolish decision
so you don't have to go off to some
foreign country and die in some foreign
war
to be dead all you have to do is make a
careless decision or a foolish decision
at the wrong time and we're all tempted
what was that voice I heard this morning
that said you don't have to do your
exercises this morning you hear that
voice too you're running like voice too
you can make up for it you know when you
get back from your seminar trip
and I said no I've got to do at least a
modified version even though I'm late
and you just you know that's every day
Chris
the waitress irritates you
and now you've got a choice Let It Go
or make a big deal out of it and
embarrass everybody
's got the choice here's a good one I'm
walking into Nate now's in Beverly Hills
where by the way
uh two mornings ago there was Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar I had a nice chat with him
um
I walked before I walk into the
restaurant I I've got two quarters to
put into the machine to get my paper
a man walks up just ahead of me puts in
two quarters opens it up takes out his
paper and he holds the door of the
dispenser open and says to me go ahead
and take you a copy
said you know the newspaper can
certainly afford it
and he offered for me to take my life
right new newspaper for free
what do you do yeah
here's a nice person
I got a judgment call to make
fortunately
maybe because I mama was watching I
don't know
no my upbringing I said no thank you and
he looks very shocked said okay close
the door and I put in my two quarters
and got my paper
because the key is if you take the free
paper it could affect you for the rest
of the day
something will sort of nag at you and
say why would you want to feel like this
to save two quarters right
and sometimes when you do it
now that's a good lesson then you won't
do it anymore because you just don't
want to feel that way anymore that means
Maybe
part of that's how you've been raised
right those little moral questions that
you you go through and guilt can be a
good teacher yeah it is yeah
yeah I don't want to feel like this and
maybe it nags at you for a whole week
and you say wow for two lousy quarters I
took me the free newspaper never again
and uh but sure enough uh you know the
next time we're tempted again it doesn't
mean that the Temptation goes away we
get a little bit stronger about you know
saying yes to the positive side yeah
because that's the way I really want to
live my life after the Bible what uh
what other books would you recommend for
people to pick up that shaped and
influence your life you know I'm big on
Shakespeare and
um
Think and Grow Rich change my life
um the richest man in Babylon helped me
become a millionaire by the time I was
31.
um
then all of the
I'm a big student of History
Durant will and Ariel Durant wrote all
these books on history I go through some
of those
one book I've got to help lay the
foundation for my own Library it was a
book called how to read a book by
Mortimer Hadler yeah and in this book
he's got a list of what he considers you
know the best books ever written yeah
and I use that as sort of a centerpiece
for my for my library yeah did you ever
meet David Schwartz uh Magic of thinking
big no never meant that's a good book
yeah yeah terrific book yeah
then there's a book that years ago when
I was in my
late 20s
um as a man thinketh by James Allen yeah
where each sentence is almost like a
whole seminar short little book yeah but
uh Dynamic yeah in its effect
become a good reader I say now in my
seminars right the books you don't read
won't help
two books a week in a 10-year period and
you've read it read a thousand books
and if over the next 10 years you read a
thousand books
it will dramatically affect every
phase and part of your life yeah
you talk about uh the two pains
everybody has to experience one of two
pains and I think that it it it's one of
my favorites that you talk about because
it's so profound and it's so true and
it's so final it is it is universal that
you will experience one of the two pains
can you talk a little bit about yeah the
little illustration about the newspaper
is a good illustration
the pain of discipline or the pain of
regret
go for the discipline because it weighs
ounces
uh the regret weighs tons
because it can accumulate
discipline versus regret
um the discipline could be painful
but the regret is usually an
accumulation
that could eventually become
overwhelming
so better the discipline now
but it's true and
you know real life if you discipline
yourself to plant the crop in the spring
you now have a chance for a multiply to
harvest in in the fall
um what you don't plant won't multiply
what you neglect
I neglected to buy from my friend eight
years ago he offered me this little tiny
condo one bedroom
little small place in Carmel California
yeah
Ron said I want eighty thousand dollars
for this condo I said Ron that's insane
uh nobody's gonna pay eighty thousand
dollars for this condo he said okay
if you change your mind let me know I'm
ready to sell
and uh he put it on the market last year
toward the end of last year
for six hundred fifty thousand dollars
you know that was one of those
times I should have listened to the
positive side of the voice it's sitting
why not buy and he kept it for another
eight years right
so it's in his prayers every night
before he goes to sleep you know thanks
the good Lord I didn't buy this condo
eighty thousand to six hundred and fifty
thousand wow
um
everything's lessons to learn right I
could have I should have
I'll do a better
job in the future of making wiser
decisions that's the best counsel we can
possibly have yeah
um whether it's you know a bit of waste
of time that we could tighten up on or
whatever it is uh why not do it
then I think one of the greatest joys
for me and of course I've made it now
has become a business is passing along
and sharing ideas with others that have
profoundly affected your own personal
life
it's a great joy whether I do it in a
novice Siberia or whether I do it in
South Africa
or India or anywhere in the world
um
the opportunity
that if you say something uniquely
enough
that it could affect
somebody's life or begin the process of
affecting somebody's life it's an
awesome experience yeah you have a list
of things that people should do
everybody should what does it have a
Manhattan in Manhattan and oh yeah those
life what are some of those experiences
you think everybody should do drink a
Manhattan in Manhattan yeah
should have Australian lobster tails in
Australia yeah
you should eat Boston baked beans in
Austin
Maui onions are
delicious but you have to eat Maui
onions in Maui it's a lot better than
the Walla Walla onions I'd rather eat
onions if you have to eat onions Maui
better than it's a fun list to make yeah
yeah
we gotta drink Canada Dry in Canada yeah
yeah if you think long enough you can
come up with a pretty good list of
saying hey that sounds like experiences
that I'd like to have how are you
spending your time gotta have a
Singapore Sling in Singapore Singapore
yeah yeah I just I was there just uh
three or four months ago Singapore yeah
it's a fun list and it's just deck them
off yeah but then I talked about you
know you gotta drink in an Arizona
Sunset and you know walk the white
beaches of Carmel and you know just
start making this list let it inspire
you yeah
um
I started teaching this long time ago
and it's surprising how many people come
up to me and say you know I've added to
my list I'm working on the list you know
20 years ago when I heard you say this
here's some of the places I've gone and
I probably never would have gone if I
had never heard your seminar that's
that's exciting yeah
how are you gotta have an Idaho baked
potato in Idaho yeah
you're spending a little you can have
one in Beverly Hills and it's okay but
you know make the trip yeah just to say
you know I had an Idaho baked potato in
Idaho yeah so how are you spending your
time now when you're not traveling you
uh
well I used to ride the Jeep trails on
my dirt bike
but my daughter finally persuaded me
daddy she said you know age 75 I'm not
so sure so
that's sort of passing away but I used
to love to do that yeah it was one of my
getaway times
you know up on top of the mountains
riding the Jeep trails
and uh either alone or with somebody and
and uh good good way to get away yeah no
traffic no traffic lights
uh time alone I think is is really
essential sure
um to get away
contemplate think Wonder
something I'm doing now is working on
the multi-purpose seventh day
it says you know work six rest the
seventh but I'm calling the seventh day
now multi-purpose
spirituality and friendship and get away
and so on but I'm also saying Chris that
seventh day shouldn't be a little bit of
time spent reviewing the last six days
who did I not meet what didn't I do what
did I miss
what should I tighten up and then make
better plans for the next six days
I'm gonna catch up the next six days
some of this that I've missed the last
six so that's part of the multi-purpose
of the seventh day review six
get better ready for the next six yeah
well this has been fascinating 57
minutes and uh we could have been here
all day and sometimes we do we go to
this yeah we do the all day or the
two-day Jim Rohn seminar and so I just
want to say thanks for coming in and
pleasure and spend a little bit of time
and giving us some of your stories that
you tell all around the world and truly
have impacted so many lives including my
own and I appreciate that thanks Chris
yeah I appreciate it it's fun to be here
thank you to see my recent one-on-one
with Jim rohn's Protege Tony Robbins
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on me beautiful
children you have how many people love
you the quality of your life is where
you live emotionally